(upbeat music)
(mumbling loudly)
- Iceland is so cool.
It's like, I'm looking for
somewhere to eat for dinner
and every other results on
Google maps is fish and chips.
- [Narrator] A mobile Fish and Chips.
(upbeat music)
- Just do two orders
of fish and chips.
- Yeah.
- So I'm in Iceland
and I just found out that the
UK went to war with Iceland
several times between the 50s and the 70s,
over one thing, fish and chips.
I'm not kidding,
there were three conflicts
between the 50s and the 70s
over fish that they
use for fish and chips.
- [Narrator] Let's have
some fish and chips.
(upbeat music)
- Fish, and chips, this is real.
I wanna tell you the story buckle up.
Yeah, what kind of fish is it?
- It's Cod.
- [Narrator] Would you
like some fish and chips?
- [Narrator] Iceland, it is above all
the home of the vital fishing industry.
NATO's banner flies proud.
- [Narrator] The Iceland is
unilaterally extended at fishing
up to 12 miles.
- Yes, I know I have done fish wars.
(dramatic music)
In multiple different permutations,
from India, Sri Lanka, Prawn Wars
to US, Canada, Fish Wars.
Well, here's another installment
of how fish make it really
hard to draw borders
because they live in the ocean
and so countries fight over them.
(soft music)
(water splashing)
(wind blowing)
(mumbling loudly)
To understand why the UK
would go to war with Iceland,
you have to understand fish and chips.
Fish and chips are a giant deal in the UK,
it's like, I need to get those stats up.
A quarter of Britons, eat
fish and chips once per week.
- First thing I think we
ought to take a look at
is an English pub.
- Pubs all around the
country serve millions,
tens of millions, hundreds
of millions of meals,
of fish and chips, every year.
It is an institution, it is a
part of the cultural fabric.
(soft music)
However, Britain doesn't have enough fish
to upkeep this demand for fish and chips,
so where do they turn to?
- [Narrator] Iceland.
- So the fish that they
use for fish and chips
is called Cod.
(soft music)
Cod is a delicious buttery creamy fish.
But do you know who else loves Cod?
Iceland, in fact, you might argue
that Iceland loves Cod more
than any other country on earth.
If you need proof of how
much Iceland loves Cod,
you just got to go into
one of these grocery stores
and you will see it right on the shelves.
(dramatic music)
- Okay, who wants to try
some dried aged Cod?
- Not me!
- So yeah, Iceland loves Cod.
In fact, they used to have Cod (chuckles)
on their coat of arms,
like it is a part of
their national identity.
And to understand why
they love Cod so much,
you just need to look at the
oceans around this island.
(upbeat music)
(birds chirping)
These waters surrounding Iceland
here in the North Atlantic
are some of the most
well-stocked waters on earth
with fish, especially Cod.
This country has relied for centuries
and continues to rely deeply on fish.
I've been driving all around this country,
deep into the west fjords
and all around every region
of this country.
Everywhere I go, I see fish and fishermen
and fishing infrastructure,
the lifeblood of this
country of Iceland is fish.
(soft music)
So you can see where this is going,
the British loved their fish and chips,
which comes from Cod.
Iceland loves their fish
generally, especially their Cod
and for centuries, this
hasn't been a problem.
Iceland has been able to
fish their abundant waters
and Britain was also able
to come into these waters
and fish them for themselves
but after World War II,
that started to change.
(soft music)
(birds chirping)
(bell ringing)
(acknowledging loudly)
Hello, hi there.
Like, crack them open, put 'em on a pan?
- Yep, you can do that too.
(engine roaring)
- You guys, I bought eggs
from a bird I don't really
know what it, is that one okay?
- Why did you?
Those really (exclaims), no.
- We are eating these eggs.
- I don't wanna eat.
- We're gonna eat them?
- We're going to eat these eggs.
- Oh no!
(eggs sizzling)
- Man, it feels so good
to be on the road again,
after a year and a half home, so good.
- [Narrator] The Cold War
(mumbles) by the (mumbles),
for all Europe, comes at last to Germany.
- You have to understand
that after World War II,
the entire world changed.
Suddenly you have these super powers,
especially the United States,
calling the shots on what
a new economic world order
was gonna look like and that
came with a lot of trade.
Suddenly, if you had an
abundance of some resource,
you could ship it somewhere else
and make money for your country.
So Iceland started to
participate more and more
in the Global Fish trade.
They had so much fish in their waters
outside of their country
and they were like, we should
just start like shipping
this abundance to other people
and making money for our country.
(upbeat music)
But when they started to
go out into their waters
to fish more and more,
what they saw was a bunch
of British fishermen
out in their waters who had
been fishing there for years.
- [Narrator] Well, hello there, chaps.
- And the British were like,
"Well, you don't technically
have any claim over this water,
"it's technically international waters,
"you've never claimed
it, so we can fish here."
And Iceland was like, "You're
right, let's change that."
Iceland's territorial waters
where they exclusively could fish
only extended four nautical
miles off their coast,
not very much.
The British were like, "Cool,
like we don't need to go
"into your little four mile zone."
So Iceland, this tiny country was like,
"We're gonna extend it to 12 miles."
The British were now technically fishing
inside of Icelandic waters.
But Britain, one of the most
powerful countries in the world
was like, "Cool, there's
this island nation
"of 170,000 people with no military
"and they've just declared
"that their boundary goes 12
miles into the ocean, cool."
And they totally ignored it.
- Try and stop me.
(dramatic music)
- So it's the 1950s, Britain
is fishing, fishing, fishing,
their fishing ships Cod
off the coast of Iceland
and Iceland has no Navy, they have no way
of really enforcing this
besides their coast guard.
So they send their coast guard
out to detain the fishermen,
the British fishermen and this
works for like two seconds
until the British sends
in their like legit Navy
to scare off the coast guard
and thus begins the Cod Wars.
(whooshing loudly)
I wanna say thank you to today's sponsor,
which is Skillshare.
I've used Skillshare for many, many years,
long before they came to
sponsor a YouTube video.
Skillshare is a giant
repository of amazing classes
and tutorials on every
subject you can imagine.
It's a huge community of curious people
who want to learn different skills
from Photoshop to illustrator,
to entrepreneurial skills.
They even have classes on meditation.
There's one about
meditation for creativity,
which I'm a big fan of.
The cool thing about Skillshare
is you pay one monthly price
and you get unlimited access
to all of these tutorials
and classes and courses.
Skillshare is offering
the first thousand people
who click the link in my description,
one month for free of Skillshare,
unlimited access to all of this material.
In one month's time of free Skillshare,
you could take dozens of
these classes and learn tons.
So, Skillshare is for the
creative, entrepreneurial,
anyone who wants to learn,
Skillshare is a fantastic place for you.
So click that link in my description,
doing so signing up helps
support this channel,
but it also gets you a
month free of Skillshare.
Thank you, Skillshare for
sponsoring this video.
(soft music)
(mumbling loudly)
So it's now, like the 1950s
and the Icelandic coast guard
is holding their ground.
They're showing up to the ocean
whenever they see British ships
and they are confronting the Royal Navy.
They are not backing down,
even though they are a tiny
country with no firepower
and no leverage,
they are not backing down
because they freaking love Cod.
- It's delicious.
- I'm like, dude, Iceland
punching above your weight here,
this is amazing and guess what?
It works!
The world Navy backs down and
Britain finally recognizes
this 12 nautical mile boundary
that Iceland unilaterally
declared for themselves.
The first Cod War is over.
(bell ringing)
(soft music)
And now, we are entering
the west view wards.
Hold on, look at the map.
We're in this RV
and I'm not really sure it's
gonna handle these gravel roads
but we will quickly find out
if it does handle these gravel roads.
I'm just excited to see Iceland
at some of its most rugged,
here we go.
So now we are in Cod Peace.
Cod Peace lasts for about 10 years,
but Britain is getting
tired of their expensive Cod
for their fish and chips.
They want more Cod and Iceland
is the place to get it,
so they come back.
So British ships are now showing
up into the Iceland zone,
leaving the waters depleted.
Iceland will not have this.
They freaking love their Cod,
they're not gonna let Britain steal it,
So they decide to up the ante
and they declare a 50
nautical mile boundary.
They're like, all of
this water is now ours,
back off Britain.
This really pissed off
Britain and not just Britain,
but also west Germany and Denmark
because now Iceland's water expansion
was now getting into the
waters of these other countries
who had fisheries in this area.
But Iceland didn't care, they're like,
"Listen, we love Cod,
"this is like the best fishing
in all of the Atlantic,
"we are not backing down,
"even though we have no army
"and we only have 170,000 people."
- I'm not fucking leaning!
- Cue Cod Wars, Number two.
- Let's get ready to rumble!
(bell ringing)
(cheering loudly)
- [Narrator] In 1972,
again, without international legal backing
and increased it to 50 miles.
- The UK took this one to court first
and International Arbitration
ruled in favor of the UK.
They're like, "Dude, Iceland,
"you can't just extend your waters
"50 nautical miles into the
ocean, you can't do that."
And guess what Iceland said?
- Yeah, well, just watch me.
(laughing loudly)
- And they just totally ignored it.
(soft music)
- So even though the most
powerful countries in the world,
plus some of their friends
and an international court
ruled against Iceland,
Iceland dug in their heels and was like.
- I'm not fucking leaving!
- Britain is getting tired
of this, they're like,
"Come on guys, we need
to fish these waters.
"we need our fish and chips,
"like you have no standing
here, we're done."
So they send in their Navy once again.
♪ Mama mia, here I go again ♪
The British Navy decides to
escalate things a little bit
and start ramming the
Icelandic coast guard boats.
- [Narrator] Continued the skirmish
which ended in yet another (mumbles).
(horn blaring)
(upbeat music)
- No more warning shots, no
more soft core standoffs,
we are now ramming each other.
This leads to a series of
standoffs in the North Atlantic,
between Icelandic coast
guard and the Royal Navy,
the most powerful Navy on earth.
(exclaiming loudly)
These fish and chips people,
they love their fish and chips.
- It's really good.
(laughing loudly)
It's delicious.
- So, does Iceland back down
in the second Cod War and say,
"Okay, fine, the International
Court ruled against us,
"Britain and West Germany
and Denmark don't like this,
"we're just gonna chill out."
No, they didn't, they
kept it up and in fact,
they decided to pull out their
one major piece of leverage
in all of this, which was
their alliance with NATO.
- [Narrator] NATO land is
composed of 14 different nations
with a combined army, 7 million strong.
- Easily, my favorite part about Iceland
is that you can be driving through
some random mountain paths,
like we've been doing,
at midnight and you can
wander upon waterfall
after waterfall, after
waterfall that are just there.
They're just there.
Just look at this waterfall
that I'm looking at.
It is insane.
Iceland was a member of NATO.
- [Narrator] NATO was
founded April four, 1949
by 12 nations of widely
different languages and customs.
During its six years,
NATO has well proved it's power for peace.
- And they occupied a
fairly important role
because of where they exist,
they exist right here
in the North Atlantic,
a very strategic place.
So Iceland decides to
pull out their wild card,
the thing that they've been
holding onto this whole time,
which is we will withdraw from NATO
if you do not recognize our
50 nautical mile boundary
of the ocean.
If Iceland withdraws from NATO,
because of something the British did,
the US is gonna be pissed at Britain.
- No, let go of him (yells).
- Tell that bitch to be cool.
- I'm gonna kill you.
- Say, bitch, be cool.
- Be cool, honey bunny.
- Be cool.
- Tell that fucking bitch
to chill!
- Be cool, honey bunny.
- Chill that
fucking bitch out!
- So Britain was like,
"Okay fine, you win 50 miles, you got it."
- Gosh, darn it, I give up.
It's yours, you can have it.
- Cod Wars, Episode Two is over.
(ringing softly)
Iceland wins again (laughs).
So this is now the
second time that Iceland,
this tiny country with no
military has like bested
one of the most powerful
countries on earth,
all because of fish.
They freaking love fish here,
like don't mess with Iceland's fish.
But this isn't over.
It's the 1970s
and we are about to commence
Cod War, Episode Three,
Return of the Cod.
(soft music)
(mumbling softly)
Officially made it to the
Western most point of Europe.
I think that's right,
I mean, we tried to say
we were in the Western most point of view
like two years ago, in this moment.
- [Narrator] Just a 30 minute drive
outside of downtown Sintra
is the Western most point
of continental Europe.
- And yeah, that obviously wasn't, I mean,
it was like continental Europe.
So now we, here we are again,
in the Western most point
of Europe right here.
I don't know where we are, but
we're really freaking west.
We've been driving for like
four hours on dirt roads
to get to this cliff on
this very tip of Iceland
on the west fjords.
You know, we're here to see puffins.
What are we here to see son?
- Puffins?
- Yes.
(soft music)
- Dad, wait for me.
- I'm waiting for you, big team.
Man, these puffins are just right here.
They were just right under
our nose the whole time,
look at this.
I mean, I guess I'd seen puffins
like on Instagram or
something, but I had no idea
just how striking these birds are.
This is, photographing these birds today
has been just it's really
helped me appreciate them.
(waves crashing)
Episode Three is basically a repeat
of the last two episodes.
The British move into these
waters to get their little fish
because they want fish and chips.
More ramming, tons more
ramming, more standoffs.
Britain is not okay with this tiny country
pushing them around.
I mean, it's Britain, they're
used to just literally
taking over any country
they want in the whole world
and they're being told what to do
by this little tiny island
nation, they're not liking it.
What I love about Iceland
is that they don't just dig in
their heels and not concede,
they would push a little bit further.
So this time they're like,
"We don't just want 50 nautical miles,
"we want 200 nautical miles off our coast
"for exclusive fishing."
Britain is like, "No, this is not good,
"how are we getting bested
every time we try to fish?"
This got so bad that the UK and Iceland
actually broke off diplomatic relations.
They were like really angry at each other
until the Americans come
in and they're like,
"Dude, stop it."
NATO, the cold war, nuclear weapons,
like stop crying over your fish and chips,
we have bigger priorities.
- Chill out Dick word.
- And so they backed down
and they recognize the
200 nautical mile claim
that Iceland was asserting.
It turns out a couple of
years later, the UN developed
the United Nations
Convention On Law of the Sea,
a big document that actually codifies
that every country gets 200 nautical miles
of exclusive economic activity.
But Iceland was already
thinking in these terms,
they're like the exclusive
economic zone hipsters,
like they were far (chuckles)
ahead of everyone else.
(soft music)
There are always sheep on
the side of the road here,
including loads of baby
sheep that are so precious,
it always seems like
they're about to dart out
in front of the side of the road,
giving us loads of anxiety,
but they're very cute.
She has never seen rain deer before,
so she's taking in the reindeer.
(exclaiming softly)
Pretty special?
- Unbelievable.
- So, what are the Cod Wars teach us?
Well, as an international relations guy,
I'm sorta like, this doesn't square up
with a lot of the theories
that I learned in school.
In school, we learned
that when countries trade
with each other and with when
they're bound by alliances,
they tend to cooperate better than ever.
In this case, what you see
is countries that are bound to each other
through Alliance and through
trade who are not cooperating
because they are bound to each other
by trade and institutions.
In fact, one of the major
bargaining chips in the war
was the fact that Iceland
was gonna withdraw from NATO.
They use the institution as leverage.
- [Narrator] We have declared
that the Icelandic law
will be upheld and I have on
that law, nothing more cliche.
- All I have to say, this
is a super unique case
of a tiny country using its leverage
to basically make
one of the most powerful
countries in the world concede
and it totally worked.
- This is me, all right,
I'm not a fucking athlete,
this is my fucking way,
this is how I work.
- But the bigger lesson
for me is, and the thing
I'm gonna take away, is
don't (beeps) with Iceland
when it comes to fish.
(ringing softly)
Okay, see you later.